I've studied 101 viral hooks from the
greatest copywriters to ever live. Then
I collected all those hooks, turned them
into templates, dissected their viral
patterns, and put them in one document.
I'm going to show you how to use that
document alongside AI to write viral
hooks in seconds. I'm going to give you
everything that you need, the hooks, the
prompts, the step by step. So, stick
around. Okay. If you don't know me, my
name is Alan Draon. I've built an entire
community around the art of copywriting.
over 10,000 copywriters. Trust me, I'm a
number one bestselling author and I've
sold over $180,000 of my own digital
products using my own skill set of
copywriting. I'm going to teach you and
break down in this video. All right, so
let's hop over to my MacBook and I'm
going to give you an over-the-shoulder
view of exactly how to do this. All
right, check this out. So on my screen,
you should see 101 super sticky hook
templates by me, Alen Dragoo. So
basically what I've done here is I've
taken the entire concept of viral hooks
and I've even put in the seven
commandments of hook writing. So
basically the seven things that are the
cardinal sins if you miss these. Okay, I
put these in the document and then I
went down and look at this 101 hook
templates where not only do I find real
hooks that went viral and that sold a
ton, I break them down with an example,
a templated version and why it works.
and often times give credit if I know
who it is. My evidence-based skincare
routine. My evidence-based what method
or routine. Credit to Aliab on that one.
Why you're always tired, right? Another
Aliab over here. Uh we've got a couple
of those. Got some Dan Kennedy in here.
Some Frank Curran. So, basically took
viral headlines from copywriters,
creators, all that stuff. Compiled them.
And so, what we're going to do here is
we're going to come in here and we're
going to download this document to our
desktop, which I've already got. for you
to get this document. There's a link in
the description below. You put your
email in and I email it directly to you.
Very simple PDF document. Okay. So, once
you have it downloaded, you're going to
open it. It's going to look just like
this. You're going to hit over here in
the top download and then it's going to
come and you're going to download to the
corner. Okay. So, that's the first thing
that you need is you need to get your
document. All right. And then once you
have your document, we need the thing
that you're writing the hook for. So
maybe it's a YouTube video that you have
the script of or an online article, an
email newsletter. Let's say it's some
ads that you're writing. Let's go with
ads because this one's going to be a
little bit harder. I'm going to show you
an example of two. Okay, so let's do
this. First thing is let's say you are
writing ads for a client and you need a
banger hook for these ads so they
convert high. One of the things that I
like to do is a quick two-step process
is not only are we going to give uh
Claude, which is my preferred AI of
choice, especially for writing. We're
not only going to give Claude the 101
hook templates, but let's say we're
writing for uh AG1. Let's go to AG1's
website. Okay. And they have a ton of
content on here. All right. And I'm
going to Here's a little trick. I'm
going to file and I'm going to save this
website page as HTML on my desktop.
Okay. So, I'm going to save that HTML on
my desktop. Then, we're going to go back
to Claude and what we're going to do is
we're going to add two files. We're
going to add the HTML and we're going to
add the hooks. Okay. And then the next
thing is we are going to copy and paste
a prompt that I'm going to put down
below. I've already got the prompt where
it says, "Hey Claude, I want to write
meta ads for my new client, AG1. I've
uploaded two things for you. 101 super
sticky hook templates and the HTML page
for my client AG1. I want you to study
the HTML page to fully understand the
context of what we're writing for. Then
I want you to write me 10 different hook
options using the information you learn
about the client and the specific hook
templates I provided you. We're going to
give it to Claude and it's going to
start dissecting. It's going to do this
thing where it starts analyzing uh the
templates. It's going to start breaking
down the HTML. It's going to cut through
the PDF cuz sometimes it's got a uh PDFs
are a little bit harder to cut through.
But it's going to start reading the
templates and then it's going to start
feeding us. Yeah, here's what it says.
Let me extract the text from the PDF.
Then it's going to start feeding us
headline options. In the meantime, while
it's doing this, I've got this hooks
Google Doc open. You want to go ahead
and step two, open a Google doc. You
want to open something where you can
start moving the data that you prefer.
AI is not doing the work for you. It's
setting you up to do the work. All
right, so check this out. We're going to
go back and it's given us a bunch of
hooks. Now, we're going to read them
based on the hook templates. So, like
check this out. Warning, don't even
think about taking another multivitamin
until you read this. That's a great
headline. I love that. That's freaking
awesome. That would slap in an ad. So,
I'm going to use this. I'm going to put
that one over there. And it tells me
which one it got it from. It got it from
template three. Okay, good to know. Do
you make these mistakes in daily
nutrition? Uh, that's okay. Why you're
always tired? Seven nutrition myths
ruining your energy. Ooh, I like that.
That's nasty. Okay, so I'm going to come
in there. I'm going to snag that one. My
evidence-based morning routine for all
day energy. N The simple truth about gut
health. Why your supplements aren't
working. That could be interesting to
the target market. Scientists prove nine
out of 10 people can have better gut
health in 30 days. Oh, I like that. So,
obviously, if you didn't know what AG1
is, it's a supplement. It's a green
powders. I'm using AG1 as a great
example because I assume the majority of
people do know what this is. So, it's a
green powder supplement. And this is
great. Little nutritional gaps that keep
you tired, foggy, and running on empty.
That's okay. If you got 60 seconds each
morning, I guarantee this will transform
your energy and your health. That could
be good. That could be good. That needs
some tweaking, which is exactly what
we're doing here. All right, so let's do
this. Now, sometimes I get three or
four. I like to say, you know, give me
10 more
using the same templates. Okay, so
there's a hundred in there, right? You
could ideally go for all 100. And what I
like to do is I like to get as many
options as possible to help me think of
different angles whether I wrote an
article or whether I'm writing ads.
Especially if I'm writing ads because
you want five or six options. Let's
let's do a couple more of these and then
we'll actually break them down. I took
AG1 for 90 days. Here's what happened.
That's a freaking great hook. People
love that. That's that's a killer hook.
Okay. The lazy man's way to complete
nutrition. That's a classic headline,
but still works like crazy. Okay. The
number one daily habit for longevity.
Ah, it's all right. What if your morning
drink actually covered? No. Who else
wants morning energy, better gut health,
and sharper focus? That's okay. I wasted
$3,000 on separate supplements. This one
drink. Yeah. Okay. Sick. Fantastic. All
right. Let's say now we've got a handful
of those. Okay. Let's go back to our
Google doc. Now, in our Google doc, we
have collected, let's see, like six or
seven of these. One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, seven headlines that
could all be potential bangers for ads.
Maybe I want to pair it down to three
and then write the ad out myself. But I
highly recommend you actually partnering
with this headline and saying, "Okay,
how can I tweak this? How can I make
this better?" Like this one. Warning,
don't even think about taking another mo
a multivitamin until you read this.
Okay, I may see something like this and
be like, "Hey, multivitamin after doing
my research is probably more like a like
50 plus year old target audience where
they don't say that like I'm I'm trying
to reach 30 40 year olds." So, I might
say some something like, "Don't even
think about taking another supplement
until you read this." This is where
you're using your copywriting knowledge
to my uh to mess with these headlines to
make them even stronger. Why you're
always tired. Seven nutrition myths
ruining your energy. I might mess with
like nutrition myths. Seven food myths
ruining your energy. Seven supplement
myths. You have to think about your
target audience in the best way
possible. So, I'm going to mess with a
few of these, right? If you got 60
seconds each morning, I guarantee to
transform your energy and health. Well,
let's do something specific. Like if you
look back in the uh seven commandments,
right? Specificity is the sauce. Let's
make that more specific, right? And here
uh I guarantee to transform let's say
something like I guarantee to transform
your brain fog
into deep clarity. You know, something
like that could absolutely slap because
now you're being specific instead of
just your energy. I'm say your brain
fog. Somebody who has brain fog is
immediately going to be like, "Whoa, I
would love that." And so that's how you
start playing with headlines like this.
Okay. Now, that's how to write ads using
like a website HTML, the hooks, and all
that stuff. But I'm going to show you an
even simpler version, something you're
probably doing way more often, and that
is like writing threads, writing
articles, blog posts, whatever it is,
online content to grow your audience,
maybe even emails and things like that.
So, one of the things I like to do is I
like to write all of my content inside
of notion or Google Docs. Then you can
export that content to your desktop.
Like, here's an article that I wrote.
I'm going to upload this article to
Claude, which is uh a YouTube video, an
article that I wrote on how to change
your life with deep writing. I'm going
to upload the markdown version. And I'm
going to tell Claude, "Here is an
article I wrote. I want you to give me
10 hooks using the same process. We just
used templates and all, right? Tell
Claude." Claude already knows what to
do. So now it's going to study the
markdown. I like the markdown version
because it's it's um doesn't have to do
as much work via the PDF version. So now
Claude is going to understand the
article of how to change your life with
deep writing. It's going to give me 10
different uh 10 different headlines. So
now it starts filtering us down here
like hook one. I wrote a,000 words a day
for three years. Here's what happened.
Great headline. Three years of deep
writing lessons in 10 minutes. Oh, I
love that. The time compression. This is
a really good one. This is a really good
one. Super time compression is always
killer. I may start a new tab here. Like
if I'm doing the article, right? I'm
going to do this one. This one's AG1,
right? And then this one's article,
right? So, I'm over here and then you
tab. I'm taking these. I wasted two
years writing inconsistently. This
fourstep system work. Ah, it's all
right. Right. If you've got 60 minutes
each morning, I guarantee you'll write
more than you ever have. This one's a
similar headline. I wish you would use
some different hooks. That's why you got
to tell it to do it multiple times.
Okay. Fantastic. The lazy man's way to
writing. use totally different
templates in the 101 super sticky
hook templates, not just
the same ones. Okay, so now we're going
to prompt it to go ahead and get us
totally different templates. Oh, here we
go. Here we go. Here we go. Now we got
some fun ones. Okay. Do you want to
write a million words this year? Oh, I
freaking love that. freaking love that
because that's that's a huge promise and
a big pain point for a lot of people.
Steal this four-step writing system that
generated me 221K. Killer killer hook.
Any one of these could be like 80%
there. Uh how I write really fast 1
million words per year. Oo, that could
be very interesting. A playoff Aaliyah
Doll's headline. Why you're always too
busy. No, I don't like that. The only
way to write a thousand words a day
without quitting your job. Oh, I like
that too. Okay, so now got a bunch of
these. You might prompt it a bunch of
times and be like, "Hey, give me 10
more. Give me 15 more." Right? There is
a 100 hooks in there. And then from
there, you now have a killer starting
point to either start your ad, start
your articles, or in reverse when you're
done with them. Now you're dominating
with headlines. So super simple. All you
need is the 101 super sicky hooks, which
I gave you down below. You need very
simple, not sophisticated prompts,
right? Stupid simple prompts. put those
into Claude, which I prefer Claude over
Gemini and Chat GPT as far as writing
goes. And then bam, you have a bunch of
stuff. So, I hope that was helpful for
you. And if it was, consider liking this
video and subscribing to the channel. It
tells me that you want more valuable
copywriting content like this. If you
got a second, feel free to watch the
next video. I got a ton of valuable
content like this. I appreciate it.
Thank you so much. Enjoy the hooks.
Enjoy the writing. And I'll catch you on
the next one.